voilà jean c'est à vous et de 10 à auray
mariton georges froid didier viande
vient de s'ajouter cette semaine à la
longue liste des candidats à la primaire
dans la cabine au figuré est ce que
cette multiplication des candidatures ne
démonétise pas un peu le l'engagement
que représente le fait d'être candidat
la la la la présidence de la république
mal à l'elysée oui je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle par les
primaires sur la base d'un projet d'une
passion d'un engagement d'un combat que
je mène
d'autres pourraient mal et je trouve que
d'autres ne le mène pas sur cette
exigence de liberté et de valeurs qui
serait plus banal probablement dans
d'autres pays qui s'en sortent mieux que
nous mais en france il ya toujours une
certaine hésitation par rapport à la
liberté un pays qui s'est construit avec
beaucoup de dirigisme par rapport aux
valeurs un pays
hélas très complexée par rapport à son
identité
je porte cela parce que c'est
indispensable une ligne jeudi et cinq
candidats aux clients neva je porterai
d'accord qui dit plus de candidats dit
aussi moins de parrainage disponible
c'est mathématique
vous devez en récolter 20 de la part de
parlementaires vous on est tous très
précisément aujourd'hui mais aucun
candidat n'a aucun aujourd'hui monsieur
tout simplement sur les formulaires de
parrainage n'ont pas été deux des noms
sont cités par tel ou tel candidat quand
vous discutez avec les parlementaires en
question voir que c'est plus compliqué
je vous rappelle que j'avais eu plus de
cinquante parlementaires qui avaient
soutenu au monde la présidence de l'ump
que je suis dans une relation fluide
avec mes collègues je ne les harcèle pas
en même temps le temps maintenant avance
et en effet je suis dans une démarche et
les formulaires sont disponibles à
partir de la fin du mois d'av et qui
consiste à demander aux uns et aux
autres de confirmer leur position leur
bonne engagement à mon égard dont je
suis sera en même temps c'est un travail
auquel je suis aussi attentif mais je
veux juste vous dire je reviens sur
cette affaire du nombre de candidats les
primaires républicaines aux états unis
au début il y avait plus d'une vingtaine
de candidats
la presse américaine plus courageuses et
plus travailleuse peut-être que la
presse française a été capable
d'organiser des débats
foxnews facebook c'est pas des débutants
avec dix sept candidats en deux
séquences en prime time
le soir les 10 les mieux que de vous
demander des conseils
mais oui parce que ça serait bien pour
quoi vous laisser enfermer dans l'idée
qu'au fond ce chiffre est insurmontable
moi je trouve que mes regardée aux états
unis ça fonctionne plutôt bien de même
que yi pas mais jouissent tous les trois
vous êtes très talentueux mais qui nous
disent aujourd'hui de toute manière vous
pensez tous la même chose donc d'abord
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils tombent
candidats pour prôner le mot de nicolas
sarkozy qui est dit enfin pas vous mais
certains journalistes
la semaine dernière nicolas sarkozy dit
c'est un cirque du raïs qui lisent c'est
ainsi est un signe de l'absence ou dit
certains d'entre vous pas vous vous êtes
les meilleurs mais d'autre part
construction vous dites tous la même
chose évidemment ça vous dispense de
lire les bouquins et savoir ce qu'on dit
précisément mais pas bon non
il y en a en tout cas c'est un signe de
bonne santé oui mais tant qu'à des idées
il ya un candidat qui a pas besoin de
parrainage
il s'agit de jean frédéric poisson sont
sa candidature en tant que candidat du
parti chrétien démocrate est donc pas
candidat des républicains a été validé
cette semaine par le bureau politique
est ce que vous trouvez normal qu'ils
bénéficient d'une sorte de passe droit
techniquement c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que la démarche
sans retrait de la candidature de jean
frédéric poisson n'a pas été validé en
tant que tel vous savez les débats que
nous avons eus on est le seul candidat
officiel aujourd'hui c'est pas comme ça
que ça a été présenté par les
républicains donc ça il n'y a pas deux
il n'y a pas de il le fait de certains
soirs là même les jouets fait qu'il
n'ait pas cherché par le je pense le
parrainage de moulins respectera pas les
livres exactement la même
alors je parlais de votre bouquin nous
on la lui en tout cas je vous l'assuré
ici il s'appelle le printemps des
libertés il se fit un plaisir c'était un
grand plaisir il commence par cette
épigraphe de soljenitsyne vous êtes un
russophiles averti personne sur la terre
n'a d'autre issue que d'aller toujours
plus haut prix vous voulez aller
jusqu'au bout hervé mariton le bonheur
de la france le bonheur des français
s'est créé au le bonheur c'est un
objectif très très haut et c'est ça qui
me motive en politique donc et dreux
je suis un candidat réalisé donc je suis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
parce que je pense que seul objectif je
suis pas né avec la première fois que je
me suis rasé comme margaux les sens je
ne suis pas sûr d'être posé cette
question devant la glace et c'est
probablement par rapport à d'autres et
peut-être par rapport à certains
journalistes une tare insoluble parce
que vous n'aimez avoue team jarrassé
mais en gros
la classe médiatique politique et plus
impressionné par les combattants de
toujours et voire intime qui intervient
dans le débat mais qui a plutôt fait le
boulot jusqu'à présent mais dont un
collègue disait il ya quelques mois
m'invitant un débat vous verrez le débat
avec marion ça va être passionnant il ya
des idées c'est un type super et en plus
il a une grande qualité il n'a pas
d'ambition et ben voila je présente les
choses différemment parce qu'à un moment
il me paraît indispensable de porter ces
idées ce projet qui me paraît utile à
mon pays
justement parlons guide et vous proposer
une série de mesures chaque dans votre
livre suppression de du système dh et
l'amusant paris oui alors suppression du
code du travail faisant finalement par
les cyniques modulable franchement
margaret thatcher avait à côté de vous
c'est une copine à dire général au plan
vraiment la honte et monsieur a pris du
retard doit être minutes je constate
simplement qu'ils aient des pays comme
le royaume uni vous le site et qui
aujourd'hui s'en sortent mieux donc j'ai
aujourd'hui c'est quoi les perspectives
en france quand c'est la gauche c'est le
déclin rapide quand c'est la droite
c'est le déclin lent j'ai envie de
sortir
dans cette logique là et oui je fais des
propositions l'impôt universel et
proportionnelle parce qu'on a besoin
d'un système fiscal plus juste et pas la
fausse réforme qui est celle de la rue
de la source très rapidement pour
terminer nicolas sarkozy a rappelé
encore cette semaine qu'il souhaitait
adopter un programme commun pour le
parti avant la primaire est-ce que vous
l'impression qu'ils essayent de vous
imposer un carcan idéologique excusez
moi monsieur mais corps nicolas sarkozy
continue d'expliquer que les 35 heures
c'est le nirvana en quelque sorte et que
seul sujet c'est les exos de charges par
rapport aux 35 heures quand nicolas
sarkozy dit qu'il faut baisser les
impôts plus vite que les dépenses corps
nicolas sarkozy continue de dire qu'il
faut spécialisé l'économie française au
niveau du smic en mettant tout l'effort
public sur des baisses de charges au
niveau du smic ça ça s'appelle
l'enfermement de l'économie française
dans une vision tirs dont 10 et cette
vision économique je suis radicalement
en désaccord avec ce qui s'est dit et
c'est terminé merci beaucoup